bonjour jean d'être dans la place et on
va revenir sur l'actualité de la semaine
plus dans les détails tout à fait
bonjour luc chatel tout d'abord je
souhaiterais interrogé lutte chazal
conseiller politique de nicolas sarkozy
le patron des républicains
on a parlé d'immigration a annoncé que
le débat sur le droit du sol devaient
être ouverts et faire peut-être l'objet
d'un vote par exemple sur la proposition
d'eric ciotti de limiter le droit du sol
ressortissants de l'union européenne à
laquelle nicolas sarkozy ne ferme pas la
porte
c'est assez étonnant lorsqu'on sait que
nicolas sarkozy considère auparavant le
droit du sol comme une tradition
française irréversible il a notamment
dit lors d'un échange avec jean marie le
pen en 2003 on écoute immédiatement
c'est pour ça que le droit du sang c'est
une bêtise parce que le droit du sang ne
peut pas être suffisant il faut le droit
du sol vais vous expliquer pourquoi mais
parce qu'il ya toujours quelqu'un qui a
une idée folle dans la tête parce qu'on
a toujours un sens qui est pas
suffisamment pur il faut que l'on bien
le maran pour être nommé le droit du sol
c'est la france c'est à nicolas sarkozy
en 2012
comment expliquer que trois ans plus
tard il ouvre le débat sur ce sujet qui
semblait être définitivement clos parce
qu'on n'a pas le droit d'ouvrir des
débats nicolas sarkozy n'a pas dit qui
il était d'un avis contraire de ce qu'il
a dit en 2003 il a dit simplement que il
s'est passé beaucoup de choses ces
dernières années et que ça méritait
qu'on en débatte voilà et des bac ça
veut pas dire la surenchère de petites
phrases sur un plateau de télévision
pour faire la dépêche moi je suis pour
le droit du sang toi tu es pour le droit
du sol sa possession et c'est pour ça
que moi j'appelle les uns les autres à
notre famille politique à prendre un peu
de recul et à débattre de manière
apaisée les choses j'ai dit ce que je
voulais moi ça m'amuse beaucoup d'autres
d'entendre dire que la france c'est le
droit du sol
la france gère regarder les choses
objectivement on a un droit du sol
j'avais dit à la française c'est à dire
que vous ne devenez pas français
automatiquement si vous êtes né en
france de parents étrangers
vous devenez à votre majorité avec un
seul nombre de conditions alors le
problème des écoles ouvertes
jospin avait suspendu enfin avait remis
en place en gros une automaticité à 18
ans c'est pas dire s'interroger
aujourd'hui là dessus c'est pas un
scandale très tardivement tout l'été au
monde font ça pourquoi on n'aurait pas
le droit de débattre de sa 13 e
d'affilée tout à l'heure la question des
migrations dans le monde
les rapports nord-sud c'est la question
du 21e siècle donc c'est normal qu'on
débatte donc françois fillon claude
guéant valérie pécresse qui ont tous dit
cette semaine le droit du sol c'est
gravé dans le marbre
il faut pas y toucher voulez vous leur
dites aujourd'hui
bah si on peut en discuter il m'a
d'abord réalisé dans le détail leurs
déclarations et non pas tous dit
exactement ça ils ont dit qu'ils étaient
favoris a été assez car ils ont des kiss
défavorable à un principe c'est mon cas
moi je suis favorable au principe du
droit du sol parce que c'est une
histoire non pas de la république ces
histoires de la france depuis clovis en
passant par louis 10 le hutin en passant
par le général de gaulle
donc c'est l'histoire de la france
maintenant c'est pas pareil
les francs et l'europe mondialisée donc
je pense que c'est utile qu'on puisse
réfléchir sur le fond à ces questions
regardez ce qui se passe à mayotte jeudi
à mayotte ça doit nous interpeller
françois baroin qui fait partie dans
notre famille politique des gens
raisonnables et plutôt un gaulliste
social humaniste s'était exprimé sur le
sujet en tant qu'ancien ministre est une
première du genre disant qu'il y avait
des cas particuliers voilà donc c'est
tout ça qu'il faut débattre
tu meures passer à autre chose au
nutella sa marraine on va passer au luc
chatel ancien secrétaire d'état à la
consommation
j'aimerais vous réagissiez à cette
injonction de ségolène royal s'était
lundi sur le plateau de canal+
il faut arrêter de manger du nutella par
exemple parce que ça c'est l'huile de
palme ben oui mais il faut pas voilà
parce que c'est l'huile de palme qui est
à remplacer les arbres et des dégâts
considérables voulu tout une boîte en
disant faut pas manger de nouvelles font
qu'ils utilisent d'autres matières
premières cette recommandation a suscité
beaucoup de réactions notamment en
italie où est produit le nutella à tel
point que ségolène royal a été obligé de
s'excuser on écoute c'était sur public
sénat je veux pas polémiquer mais voilà
d'ailleurs j'ai fait un petit communiqué
par tweet pour tout en lui donnant les
excuses qu'il demandait en disant on va
regarder ensemble les progrès qui ont
été accomplis
voilà mais n'en faisons pas non plus
voilà c'était des propos tenus dans une
émission qui se veut un peu humoristique
mais je comprends que ça ait pu voilà
que ça ait pu soulever un certain nombre
de troubles donc je veux voilà je veux
atteindre la polémique les polémiques
elle utilise ce mot est ce que vous
comprenez que ça allait créer une
polémique justement bien sûr on retrouve
un peu la ségolène royal de 2007 qui
avait le don d'allumer des polémiques
pour ensuite faire fendre les éteindre
moi je vais vous dire j'ai twitté
immédiatement en dix ans madame royal
revendique et à la raison c'est à dire
je la soutiens revendique une écologie
qui ne soit pas punitive la même semaine
elle se prend de front deux grandes
marques de produits de grande
consommation
monsanto roundup pour le désherbant et
nutella c'est pas comme ça qu'on fera
évoluer l'écologie la politique
d'envirogaz province c'est pas comme ça
c'est pas par des caricatures c'est pas
par en montrant du doigt et imaginez les
conséquences pour une telle entreprise
imaginez en plus c'est de la
désinformation quelque part c'est
intéressant d'avoir l'information
globale est tout pour compte
mais allez dire vous n'avez plus droit
vous faut plus vous mangez est-ce que
c'est pas son rôle en tant que ministre
de mettre en garde contre un produit
potentiellement dans l'environnement ou
la santé ciss effet ce que cette façon
si c'était base et un sur des faits
exacts deux des faits scientifiquement
ville de bâle il ya eu des études qui
prouvent que sa partie haute et nous
ayons oui mais lisez aujourd'hui ce que
nutella indique sur l'évolution qui a
été celle de la fabrication de nutella
oui mais au delà la même manière ils
font du lobbying mais chacun a son rôle
dans cette histoire ce n'est pas en
justice en montrant du doigt comme ça
les entreprises que vous allez les
attirer dans notre pays et que vous
allez sauver l'écologie voilà on va
conclure par ces pour s'être continuera
venger d'ajouter là elle continuera à un
jeu du ltte la merci jean charest